all right all right thank you
so I just want to get like take a little
stock here first how many how many
screenwriters do we have here or
television writers screaming Wow okay so
a lot of writers a lot of writers and
yeah just yeah just write call yourself
a writer that's cool with me
what about producers do producers yeah
yeah pretty users now okay couple
what about directors any director isn't
here okay so if you - it's huh anything
else any other actor editors no I mean
oh okay so mostly above the line okay
and are you guys members of any guilds
or unions or professional like sag okay
DGA WGA no not yet not yet
and who's working in the industry right
now guys are okay so a few of you like
even if you're not doing the thing you
want to do but you're working in the
industry okay and how many you guys I'm
just trying to get kind of get to know
who you guys are but so I can kind of
tailor this a little bit but how many
guys are have any professionally
produced credits like not student films
or like you know short films but like
something I was you know distributed you
know feature film that was distributed
or television yeah film yeah okay yeah
so few you yeah yeah okay all right so
like you guys have been doing it so if
you've been doing it that's good you
guys anybody have an idea of why we're
here we're gonna talk about cuz okay
well okay so good yes some of that yep
well and here's why I asked that so so
my good friends Karen and David at film
courage when they reached out to me a
month or two ago and he said hey would
you be willing to you know to a like a
lecture independent film I was like yeah
that sounds great
mmm what should I talk about and they're
like whatever you want I'm like wow
independent film that's like that's like
a pretty big topic you know that's like
talking about the universe you know so I
was like well we can narrow this down
what if you guys asked your subscribers
and viewers like what they want me to
talk about instead of just talking about
what I want to talk about
maybe what I want to up not what you
guys want to hear and they were like
that's a great idea
so they reached out to you know they've
got a pretty good subscriber base and
they got a lot of feedback and we've got
all kinds of questions can you talk
about this can you asking this and so I
try to tailor an outline to what those
questions were and so it's just in terms
of the kind of things that people asked
and what we're going to put together an
outline based on those based on those
questions and so the kind of things that
people were we're asking about was you
know advice from you know to writers
from from a producer's perspective you
know how do I get a producer's attention
if I don't have a lot of credits how do
I approach a producer you know what does
a producer look for you know in a script
and I mean it's sort of let some of
these questions were pretty broad so I
tried to sort of like you to focus them
and then just sort of like the indie you
know sort of production process from
development through production financing
that sort of thing so so I try to create
an outline based on the questions that I
got and trying to try to you know answer
as many of those as it could so that's
what we're gonna do tonight we're gonna
go through those
so that's course so basically that's why
I asked you guys know why we're here
because really it came from you guys so
to speak so first you know you know the
idea here is to help you guys get your
pictures made that's that's the name of
the game it's like the first piece of
advice I want to give is like get the
picture made so you guys are probably
thinking like yeah like duh mark of
course that's what we're trying to do
we're trying to get the picture made
when I say that I don't mean from an
outside perspective I don't mean you
know go out and try to raise money I
mean try to get the picture made
internally mentally you have to in your
head you have to think okay I'm gonna do
what I got to do to get the picture made
you got to get out of your own way and
this is a mistake that I made early on
in my career was a lot of times I had
several several opportunities where I
had a chance to get a picture made and I
wanted to do it the way that I wanted to
do it and I sort of you know ignored
other possible opportunities and I'll
give you an example because stories are
fun so I had this this project called
high midnight many many years ago maybe
15 16 years ago that it went in and turn
around from Screen Gems and I got a hold
of this project and it was about
vampires in the Old West and was like I
thought was so cool and it was before
all these sort
there's no hybrid like you no vampire
there was no like 30 days of night
vampires in Alaska you know there were
priests or all these like vampires and
vampires in this there was it was kind
of very new there was maybe John
Carpenter's vampires which had sort of
an Old West but but it was sort of a
fresh concept and it was like the this
cool sort of 1892 New Mexico this
run-down sheriff teams up with this this
European vampire hunter who's been
tracking these vampires from Europe and
they've been going across the u.s. and
the Old West like terrorizing towns and
so this sort of you know rundown washed
up sheriff teamed up with this vampire
hunter to stop this this clan of
vampires sounds like this is that's so
cool I'm gonna get this made I want to
get this made on like I'm like a big
level right and I got the project set up
with anonymous content and at the time
they had done maybe Eternal Sunshine of
the spotless mind and they had done
maybe they were seeing 50 first dates
with Adam Sandler I think that was all
they had done at the time they've done a
lot since then but I gots out there I'm
like this is great I'm gonna get this
you know I I was just over the moon I'm
gonna get this picture made on this you
know big level and then my executive
left and as soon as your executive
leaves you know it's like a lot of times
your project dies right so I took it
back so I'm gonna make it myself that's
fine let me get for like ten million
dollars when we get it made myself and
my partner and I had raised some seed
capital and we hired this big casting
director Bonnie Timmerman and she helped
us get like Vincent D'Onofrio and
Elizabeth Hurley attached and Thomas
Kretchman and like Ted Raimi this is a
good cast
you know 400 picture for a horror
fiction like yeah I'm gonna get this
thing made and we found this town up in
Canada and we were like yeah this is you
know we're gonna do this and year after
year I kept going out chasing the money
chasing the mice switching out actors
switch and after I really cook we had
all we had a lot of actors on it and I
still couldn't get the money together
and then one day sci-fi channel comes to
me and they're like we'll give you
$750,000 take this move you know like go
off $750,000 it literally was like you
know like screw you and they were like
okay like they didn't care you know and
so and so years later what do you think
happened still hadn't made the movie and
I started like thinking I was like why
could I get out of my own way like I
learned that lesson too late it's like
just get the picture made I know a lot
of people are like they want to do with
this what's gonna have this actress cry
beyond this level but
a lot of times especially early in your
career if you have that project that's
that's really close in near and dear to
your heart sometimes this had better put
it in the drawer and then work on
something else you know if you really
that one has to be made a certain way go
work on something else
but get the picture made and I could
have done it for 750 I could have made
it really I'm sure I could have made it
pretty darn good you know better than
sharknado so so that's that's the first
thing I wanted to kind of mention to you
guys you know and the second thing is
but you know obviously a lot of we gonna
hear tonight's objective it's you know
it's my experience as I've been doing
this for 20 years
and it's yeah you know not everything is
I made a lot of mistakes so you're gonna
learn from some of mistakes that I made
and so that that would be my other piece
of advice to you guys let's go make some
make some mistakes go make some mistakes
go fail I know some weird but to go out
and fail a little bit go get rejected
because it's gonna happen get used to it
I just I was trying to set up a project
with Hallmark Channel I'd done a movie
with them of several years back trial
was trying to set up another movie with
them this year just found out I think
well yesterday that they're passing on
it I was like so close but that's part
of the game I was like okay well okay
move on but you know the head of
development over there I know or she's
like but if you have a Christmas thing
or whatever like oh you know I'll look
at like I have the door open that's fine
so go out and fail you know and go out
and make some mistakes so I think just
first before we get in the outline I'm
just gonna quickly I'm just gonna
quickly talk about myself a little bit
just so you know who you're oh you're
listening to and just just briefly how I
got here and my background so so you
know I'm like a sort of a product of the
80s that's how I grew up like so I saw
Ghostbusters in the theater 1984 and I
was like that's what I want to do like I
didn't know exactly when I want to make
movies I saw a movie four times in the
theater in 1984 when I was like 7 years
old this is what I want to do so those
kind of Ghostbusters Goonies Back to the
Future Beverly Hills Cop Karate Kid
Crocodile Dundee police academy now that
was like my era that's the movies that
made me want to make movies and I
remember my grandfather tells me seven
years old he's like if you love what you
do you'll never work a day in your life
sounds pretty good so I wasn't the best
student but managed to somehow
eventually get out here go to Santa by
pride to UCLA they rejected me
applied to us see got in but didn't get
into the film school got in UC Santa
Barbara which is still a good school not
as like their way way up here now but
when I went down they were good I'm like
yeah I don't know if I want to get to UC
Santa Barbara my dad says trust me
you'll like it
I'd never been a sandbar had no idea
what it was and I'm like yeah but it's
not a production school you think you'll
like it but it's so far away from LA my
dad's like okay yeah I didn't know that
I knew nothing about it
nothing I'm playing from Philadelphia
I'm coming from Philadelphia so talk
about night Nick right Philadelphia
fly-in in the cab driving through campus
girls in bikini surfboards right bikes
palm trees I'm like wow I hit the honey
pot you know and I mean I got it on the
payphone as soon as I got there called
my best yeah one of my best friends no
cell phones this is like in the 90th and
I was like you won't believe where I'm
this is amazing and it was like the best
two years of my life made a lot of
relationships but still when I got done
it still wasn't quite sure what I wanted
to do I moved down here I met up with an
old buddy of mine
from Santa Barbara and he says to me and
this is like mm and he says to me I got
a band that's gonna give me like 6 grand
to do a music video do you want to
direct it I was gonna direct it I was
like I tried directing at Santa Barbara
I don't think I was very good at it
that's didn't think I was a good
director and I said I don't think I want
to do that but I say well I'll produce
it with you he's like oh cool okay so we
went out and we did this band for this
group called the real seduction they
were MC Hammer's backup dancers but they
went on their R&B group really great
voices and so we did this this video and
we're pretty good this video is pretty
sweet
so we started doing more and we put
together a company called treasure
entertainment and and we incorporated in
no one we start in 2000 corporated no
one and and then I got a chance to
interview at UCLA to be in the producers
program my apply they take like a they
had like eight hundred and some
applicants they bring 40 people in to
interview and so they called me it as
one of the 40 and so I brought in a
portfolio of the company I was building
like this whole folder with like
profiles of you know the things we were
doing the projects we were doing
business card
most people come into the interviews at
school do it and you're already having
started a company and they were like wow
you know and they asked me to wait
outside and then they probably back in
they said well we can't tell you this
officially but you're in oh great so
went to the UCLA producers program got
my masters while I was building my
company so thank you student loans
because I kept me going while I built my
company graduated no three with my
masters and then from oh three oh seven
you know continue to build my company
with my partner we did dozens and dozens
of music videos so once you get that
first one going you start to put a reel
together someone else's I would do my
own next thing you know we get a reel
together when we start doing commercials
and then we started branching to
features that was always the you know
the idea was to do features so so we did
that and then and by the way while I'm
doing this I'm doing other jobs from oh
three like oh seven on runner I'm an
assistant I'm doing extra work I'm like
whatever I can to make money while I'm
doing these videos and we're running
around Sunset Boulevard hustling hitting
up bands trying to get whatever we can
you know whatever we can and I'm telling
you this this story because I want you
guys to know that I was doing the same
thing that you guys are doing like it's
you know it's you have to start
somewhere and it's no there's nothing to
be ashamed of running around you know
doing whatever you can do you know while
you're trying to get your project made
so so at the end of the day we built
this company up and we you know in oh
wait which I know it was a bad year for
a lot of people is a great year for
treasure Entertainment the company that
I built with my my partner so bio a
seven years in you know we we grossed
over over a million dollars in revenues
we were getting a lot of music videos
you know Janelle Monae John Michael
Montgomery Snoop Dogg and we were doing
videos for like fake you know big
artists and we had we had a few features
under our belt all you know under a
million bucks and by 2011 I was sort of
starting to get burnt out on the the
corporate thing you know because I was
spending more time trying to run the
company than just creating product and
so in 2011 I I stepped down a lot of the
other officers decided to step down as
well the company wanted up folding but I
just I just wanted to go freelance so
what I did is I started working for
people like you like being hired and
actually I met will for example we
I was introduced by a friend and we'll
one to make make a film and we'll had a
generous benefactor and and we wound up
you know will wanna frame me onto his
project as the producer so that's from
2011 till now that's what I've been
doing is I've been working as a
freelance producer so and I just gotta
get hired
I tell people I'm usually the kind of
guy that gets hired by people who have a
script and they have money and they have
no idea what to do with it and they'd be
you know how do I take it from here to
here or I just want to direct you know
though that that's a lot of the kind of
people I get or you know it's just me I
got the money but I don't want to focus
on the day-to-day producing and I get a
lot of clients like that I also managed
writers for eight years while I was at
Treasure Entertainment so in addition to
producing I was managing writers so so a
lot of the stuff I'm going to talk about
comes from comes from that and I think I
think a good thing to remember too is
that you know and the fact that I'm
making a living doing this I mean is is
it is a dream come true you know I'm
making a living doing what I love to do
which is that my grandfather said so but
every producer is not good at everything
so I think that's something to be aware
of so for me like I hate raising money
like I'm not very good at it I don't
think I'm very good at that but I've
done it I'm gonna talk about it but it's
not something I enjoy doing so there's
there's things I enjoy doing development
working with the writers I enjoy doing
production I enjoy doing you know
working in marketing distribution I like
those aspects like those hands on I hate
raising money so I think development
that's probably a good place to sort of
get into this outline so some people are
asking me about how to get to a pretty
get to a producer as a writer especially
a writer without a lot of without a lot
of credits and I got a few questions
about like lifestyle advice which I
thought was kind of funny and said so
like one of the questions was do I need
to live in LA you know what you guys are
already here so you guys like cool
whatever but for the people watching
yeah people watching the video know
number one you don't need to be a to
live an LA to be a writer part two yes
you need to be in LA to be a writer
if you want to work so what I mean by
that is you can write for my obviously
you know if you have a computer and
final draft no and that doesn't make you
a writer any more than being having a
body makes you an actor right but it's a
craft we all know that but it's all
things being relative let's say you're a
good right
yeah you can have final draft you can
have a laptop and you can write from
anywhere but if you want to be a working
writer you need to live in a production
so that you need to live in LA you live
in New York because you need to be able
to take meetings you need to be able to
meet with the director you may be able
be on set doing rewrites you need to be
able to network if you're doing TV you
need to be in the writers room you need
to be here to do that
you know you might hear the story about
the kid from Boston who sold a spec
script or whatever he still lives in
Boston that's fine that's one sale there
gonna be a regular working writer yeah I
would advise that your big live here you
know to do those meetings to do those
rewrites so that I think that's kind of
an important important aspect I also had
a question about it is it important
believe it or not is it important to
have a good attitude does that mean
something like what is it not a good
thing right when is it not a good thing
like it's okay to have a bad attitude in
this job I mean some writers might just
think you know like like editors are
similar to like they lock themselves
away in a room they don't have to you
know interface with people a lot but yes
of course you know having a good
attitude is important it's important
because I think you know from a producer
producers perspective you're selling
yourself you're selling yourself as much
as you're selling the script sometimes
more because of the producer I'm looking
at a writer and I'm thinking like I got
to work with this guy for the next nine
months or twelve months or two years
like do I you know do I really I've
actually have turned down projects
because I'm like I don't think I'm gonna
mesh if I don't like this guy's probably
not gonna like me on the flip side of
that coin I've worked with writers that
I kind of you know like I really like to
them the project was like remember I had
um called these these two writing
clients that's and that I've read this
script prom date and it was like
I like teen comedies I've always liked
American Pie those kind of movies and
it's like that kind of like teen comedy
I'm like it really needs some work and
maybe otherwise I'd pass up I really
like these guys these guys are funny I
want to work with them so I took them on
as clients and we work together and we
wound up producing one of them I still
work with now
a friend said both of them one of them I
produced four of his movies so we still
work together and and I just took that I
took that I took the most clients
because I liked to them so so yeah good
attitude is important it's not just
about your work it's a it's it's about
selling yourself and sometimes more
important than selling the script and
then you know some people just again
they ask me you know how do I know
again I've spent in 15 nate's whatever
16 years dealing dealing with him
working with writers a big part of my
education in UCLA was development my
development professor make Lefou he was
Jodie Foster's producing partner at egg
pictures Jean she's a genius
she wrote inside out which was up for
the the Disney film which I guess was
nominated for smallest she's really
really smart when it was the story so
learned a lot from her and Matt you know
I guess I'd manage writers for eight
years and then again continuing to work
with with independent filmmakers as a
producer as well so so yeah
lifestyle-wise have a good attitude yes
and if you want to be a regular working
writer yes you should live in Le
approaching a producer without having a
lot of credits so a few questions that
you guys can can sort of ask first thing
as a writer so for those of you guys who
were writers you should ask is is does
that producer have a track record of
making the type of movies you're looking
to make it's one of the biggest things I
guess a in treasure Entertainment I'd
get query letters and we did like niche
like niche genre sort of lower budget
you know horror comedy you know it had
to be some sort of like niche genre kind
of film get like queries for
seventy-five million dollar period epics
like this isn't what we do and now
especially now again the in the sort of
digital age you guys have like this
information at your fingertips are
really no reason not to know who you're
querying right so don't send the blanket
queries out to everybody because it's
gonna get deleted I mean you're wasting
your time
if you're not query in the appropriate
people so look at people you're querying
like do they do this kind of budget
level you know okay that's like and you
guys guys work in the center she's got
it hey you have a kind of an idea of the
budget levels of your movies think you
know whether this is a low-budget movie
or
budget fast and furious or whatever you
kind of know so are they doing these
kind of budget levels is this this genre
or they're working at like you're not
gonna go to jason blum with like a Will
Ferrell comedy you know like so genre
budget is indie versus studio that's a
big deal to you know as an indie
production company or is it you know
they have a studio deal do they do big
studio pictures and you know style is
this the kind of style these guys are
hanging you know so if I think that's
gonna cut out a lot of sort of wasted
time it's just first target to target
the producer based on what you know
they're making do a little research
you've got you know IMDB you've got
Wikipedia you've got just googling them
is gonna save you a lot of time number
two
you know do these producers have a
history of working with up-and-coming
writers well things people don't think
about that I just want to get to this he
look at the this producers credit only
have twenty five credits and not one of
them is with and I've been coming right
at all with big-name writers probably
not gonna have much of a shot you know
just realistically you know but you
might also look at some of these credits
and say oh this guy like you know this
is this writer only have like two
credits and now like the second credit
is with this big okay maybe they're
working with with bigger name with a
smaller name bigger name but he's just
working with smaller writers so I think
that's that's also something to consider
third and this is also a big one do they
take on solicited material so most of
the bigger companies don't so how do you
get around that and that's that's one of
the tricks so a couple things if you
don't have a relationship there that's
always one way is you want to get an
agent or a manager or an attorney to
submit it for you if you have one of
them you know you can get you can kind
of get through the gatekeepers the
easiest out of those three and my
experience as an attorney you can find
it because you can hire an entertainment
attorney on a retainer you get somebody
again you know you got a sometimes you
got to pony up a little bit of dough I
mean you're investing in your future
right but if you're willing to sort of
you know to hire an entertainment
attorney might be able to get you know
get them to get you in the door and the
reason for that is because most most
production companies they might have
similar ideas and development they might
have similar projects that they're
working on so they don't want you to
come sue them if they make that similar
project that they already had and you
say you stole my idea they know if it
comes from an attorney or an agent
Orange
manager that that's not gonna happen
because that that agent or manager or
attorney knows the protocol and they're
gonna say to you look you know we
submitted you know through this process
you got you can't go sue them now you
know so they're there they they
understand that they're sort of a little
bit of reductive protection there so I
think you know manie's that are willing
to - to take a look at your project if
you sign a release form based on a
really good pitch but for the ones that
aren't you you gotta you have to get an
advocate to get you through that door
agent manager or attorney again agent
managers looking for clients you know
based on sort of more creative
parameters but an attorney you know they
take scripts from attorneys so that that
to me is the easiest because there's not
as much of a creative qualifier with an
attorney more of a money thing so that's
the way you might be able to get through
that door also you know what kind of
producer is the person that you want to
approach so so there's a lot of
different types of producers out there
you know do they work for hire so like
on the kind of producer I work for hire
right so I don't go out there just like
trying to like raise money in shop
scripts like people hire me you know is
that producer more of an EP or a money
guy like an executive producer because
they might be like why you know like are
you coming to me to find talent or
whatever are they a post producer line
producer I mean you know talent manager
some producers like all this guy's a
Bruce Willis movie he's only producer
because he managed the actor and he said
I want to produce her credit if you want
my actor this happened to me when I
worked for Bobby newmeyer so Bob and
Bobby was a great he was a great
training ground worked for him just
before I went to UCLA and Bobby produced
training day Santa Claus and the
quintessential indie film that started
everything as the the indie movement as
we know it
Bobby produced them it started that
movement which was Sex Lies and
videotape back in 89 so he was a great
mentor and I remember so like yes funny
but he we were doing a movie called
national security with Martin Lawrence
and Steve Zahn and you know Martin
Lawrence's manager said to Bobby you
know like if you want Martin I want to
produce I want to be a producer
it was like that's Emily well Martin I'm
a producer so you know it's it's not
like he had a specific tangible like a
new physical production or new script
development you know sometimes they're a
distribution person we know the producer
that you're going to because if they're
like oh they're just they're the money
guy but they only deal with you know
this company or whatever like hey I
don't know you know I mean know who
you're dealing with you know or if they
just do post or whatever like hey I'm
not the right guy and then think about
what assets you have to leverage
financing obviously is is one possible
asset a lot of people say well if I had
financing I wouldn't need them but
that's not necessary true sometimes you
have a little bit of financing and you
need somebody to take that little bit
and make it bigger so if you have a
little bit of financing a lot of
producers will sit up and take notice I
I have a relationship with two producers
do very very big films I think Mel
Gibson Bruce Willis these sort of
action-filled the ones that you see sort
of on Netflix you're like I never heard
of that but it's like Bruce Willis you
know those that cost like 15 million
bucks and you're like well I never went
to the theaters though and they say
they're like just come with like a
million bucks and we can take it from
there just a million we can we can use
that we can get to ten or twelve so you
know what kind of can you leverage a
little bit of Finance and that's just
one example maybe you have a hundred
thousand you could leverage it to a
million and we're going to get into
financing a little bit later but talent
attachments again especially you know
you're an actor you're taking classes
with sometimes it's like other name
actors you have a friend who's an
assistant at CAA who knows but you can
you know talent attachments name
director do you have underlying rights
to a really interesting personal life
story a book if you have some sort of
asset to leverage and I would say a
really good underlying story is one of
the easiest things to get to I have
again a mutual friend of will and I Eric
he went and he got rights to this really
cool story called Panama unit it was a
true life as a newspaper about these
I guess they were like some sort of law
enforcement in the town the Texas border
that wound up working with the drug
cartels and like smuggling drugs
themselves and then the cops had to
bring them down like they kind of became
bad guys you know and he optioned this
the life rights of like one of the guys
or something and set up with a pretty
big producer didn't have a lot of assets
or a lot of resources but he found
something he could leverage so you think
about the things the kind of things you
can leverage a book an article life
rights you found a really interesting
person you can option their life right
so you can option an article well you
have a little bit of financing or again
some sort of name those are the kind of
things that can help you get through
that door and by the way it doesn't need
to be based on like a best-selling book
or you know big video game or something
a lot of times you have producers are
interests in that sort of undiscovered
really like oh this is really cool I
never even heard of this and the reason
that producers like those things is
because they know we know it already
there's already an audience there I mean
if especially if it's if it is a book or
it's something that already has like
sort of a following it's like well okay
I know there's an audience I knew who my
audience is so again approaching a
producer without having a lot of a lot
of credits look at their track record
are they making the kind of movies you
want to make are they they have a
history of working with up-and-coming
writers that don't have a lot of credits
do they take on solicit material if they
don't can you get to an attorney that
can help you get through that door
and are they the right kind of producer
and what you have to leverage those are
the best ways to sort of get in the in
the door if you have those if you have
answers to all of those questions I
think you have a pretty good shot yeah
you know and it might again you're gonna
go out you're gonna fail it's gonna
happen you're gonna go out you might
take you a year or two years you've got
to keep plugging you have to keep
plugging another question I got was what
do I look for in a script specifically
they were asking what is Mark look for
in the script so I can't speak for
everybody but I can speak for myself and
it's probably semi Universal first is it
well written and when I say well written
first thing I mean is like just the
quality of the prose itself is it
polished
or is the formatting off spelling
grammar that drives me nuts like if it
doesn't even really like its I could
I've gotten query letters of past that
don't read like they're even written by
a native English speaker and I'm I'm
having trouble getting through why would
I read your hundred page script I can
even read your query letter so query
letters yes make sure they're well
written but that's but that's gonna be
my first indication of whether the
scripts gonna be well written but that's
just like I tell you guys if you just
polish your scripts and make sure it
give to a friend to reor step away from
it for five days and go back and read it
and go over all those mistakes use
grammerly something that's gonna set you
above like forty percent of the scripts
right there it's just think wow it just
tightly written the prose is strong you
know there's not a lot of you know
spelling mistakes grammar mistakes
formatting mistakes ii you know i'd say
it's part of being well written it's a
how strong of the characters that's the
next thing and this is a necessary order
of importance it's just the things i
noticed first first i just noticed the
quality of writing next thing i noticed
the character is like protagonist
antagonists are they interesting do they
have goals do they have flaws you know
what's what's sort of the arc of the
characters they change nothing but
personally bugs me more than a script
with a character that doesn't change so
i there was like that movie with george
clean you up in the air like this movie
and i was like i still like it
like why i'm like george polly doesn't
change in the end he's the exact same
person at the end of that movie that he
was at the beginning of the movie just
bugged me for some reason and that was
it as an example but nothing else george
clooney but but yeah that so you know
those kind of things
character arc you know and these are the
kind of things you can read about in
books those how to create that sort of
stuff but just that's what I look for is
strong characters characters that change
what's the concept is a concept that
intrigues me you know and that's gonna
be subjective I can't tell you what
that's concepts gonna be so it's going
to change from producer to producer but
I look at the narrative through line I
look at the structure is it you know
does it have a you know I'm a three-act
structure guy I mean it's it's not like
if you don't have a strong 3x truck sure
it's almost gonna call Youm out and say
wait your second act low point doesn't
happen on page 90 like it's supposed to
if they're not going to say that but
what an agent at CAA will do is you'll
get feedback that
yeah it's it's just not what they're
used to reading like yeah it's not
really for us it just didn't feel it
doesn't feel like the kind of stuff they
won't give you that specific note oh the
midpoint came too late they'll just tell
you it doesn't really feel like you know
the kind of thing that's right for a
client or it's not the kind of thing
they're used to reading that's why it's
kind of important at least the beginning
of play by those rules you want oblate
break the 3x structure rules do it once
you're known but the beginning play by
the rules and somebody can break the
rules and maybe somebody can make the
rules get big enough I guess no I'm not
there but breaking the rules yeah it's
you know yeah once you once you get to
that level that's you know that's that's
fun but but at the beginning play by the
rules you know so they understand that
you like Witten Tarantino you know I
remember reading Kill Bill there's one
script it was one movie was like 297
pages I read it in one sitting because
the writing was so interesting in the
action line it said something like yeah
I can remove my Thurman's name but and
the in the movie the see if it's like a
it's like a nickname remember her name
was what was it something the bride yeah
he called her bride the bride picks up
the gun he says that me action
line these are the gun I was
like and if I got that from like a
lesser-known writer I pick how amateur
but because it's Quentin Tarantino's
voice I'm like oh yeah and it kind of me
it says like yeah she's a gun
yeah I get it so kind of know who you're
you know you're who your audience is but
but show you can play by the rules for
so so if I got a script with yeah it's
well-written it's got you know strong
characters that have an arc have goals
have flaws strong structure strong
concept yeah that's that's that's that's
first and foremost I'm gonna first get
that through the query maybe I'll say
give me a synopsis or a treatment then
if I see in the treatment I'll read the
script theme is a big thing what's the
theme what's the message why are you
telling the story why like you know cool
I mean you are we supposed to learn
something from it and not every film has
to be some super self-important thing
sometimes it can just be fun but there
should be some reason why you're telling
it you know some sort of message that
you're getting across so I kind of look
at it I go is this a story or subject I
care about it could be just like I said
that teen comedy prom date just this kid
finding his confidence that's cool you
know and is really
funny it's like this old light this is
like it's light it's make people laugh
and I liked what this kid was about you
know what this kid was about and it was
it was some a simple story and I thought
people could identify with it so it's
something I personally care about so I
look at the theme again if you research
your producer and you know who you're
pitching you might get an idea of what
they're into by looking at the credits
and going hey I think I see a similar
theme any other movies that they've done
and then you know it's somebody had
asked me to they said specifically they
said can be edgy even if I'm alienating
a lot of my audience you know so I don't
know specifically what they were talking
about maybe it's a political thing or
whatever it might be alienating a lot of
my audience should I do it that's sure
as long as you feel like there's a large
enough audience to justify the budget
doesn't matter you know I mean it's like
you look at it like birth control is a
good example you mean birth control a
lot of you know devout Christians don't
like birth control but they still cells
because there's enough people it's still
like it okay but you're you know a lot
of people don't like it there's enough
people that still justify making it
right it's the same thing with a movie
right I mean if there's enough of an
audience to justify that okay you only
need a bunch of people that's a lot of
people like oh you're an alien eight
these people so if you have an audience
over here and they can justify your
budget you meaning you can make enough
be enough return based on this group of
people make your movie producer friendly
is another thing I look at so so what
would it take to take this over the
finish line producer friendly being like
if I get a script I say yeah well okay
so I need to get Morgan Freeman and Tim
Robbins to make this work and I have to
build this giant inverted pyramid in the
middle of Los Angeles and I need to have
4,000 pounds of fake snow brought in I
might look at this and go this is going
to be too much of a challenge there's
gonna be too much of a pain not that I'm
not into a challenge but I might just
look at that and say it's it's not this
is gonna be 2 to 4 the budget or
whatever it's just not producer friendly
so I'm not something I think I could
pull off personally or for the money or
what have you so so being being producer
friendly is it can easily be produced at
least in the budget range I'm working in
or what
I'm used to doing is something that I'm
gonna look at validation is a big thing
so does it come highly recommended from
someone that I know and trust like I
have a good friend mark he's a judge for
the Nichols fellowship if Mark says to
me read this dude this is really good
I'm gonna read it you know it's like the
Nichols fellowship I mean this guy you
know one of the biggest contest and that
that's another thing has it won any
contests even if it doesn't maybe come
from someone like mark if you know you
came to me and you said you know at
least a quarter maybe a semi-finalists
in Nichols Sundance lab you know blue
cat Austin final drafts big break some
of the bigger ones the smaller ones
don't mean anything telling you I mean
they don't mean anything nothing the
bigger ones it's not like one of these
things where if you do really well in 30
small ones they mean something it means
more to do well in one big one than to
do well and a bunch of small ones so
just don't waste your time with the
small it actually wrote an article about
this on a a site called funds for
writers funds f unds funds for writers
and about screenplay competitions and I
interviewed my buddy mark and you know
ask some questions about like hey tell
me about a little bit about how the
inside of this world works screenplay
competition judging and got you know
some did some research and put together
what I thought was the 10 best but
that's validation because those top
screenplay competitions are at the top
not just because the big cash prizes
which is nice but also because the
judges are well-known
you know people so I don't know who's
judging little you know
competition of you know Duluth or
whatever I don't know who's judging that
but I know we judging nickels I know
he's judging Sundance so that that's
validation you know has anyone notable
signed on that's also validation you
know I got the project set up with
Hallmark Channel because I got Luke
Perry attached and Daryl Sbarro who was
the kid in Spy Kids and orange curling
odd kid and they didn't wind up using
either of them because Daryl got too old
and Luke was on another movie when they
wanted to make it so they made with John
Schneider and
the kid from kicking and screaming with
Will Ferrell I figured his name Dylan
mcLaughlin so so we went on making it
with a different cast but I got it in
the door because Luke Perry very like
they love you know TV movie Perry so so
I think part of validation is you know
because come highly recommended from
someone you know hasn't won a contest a
major contest
does it have somebody attached that
that's those are examples of validation
and of course money does it have
financing attached and if so how much
and what kind so you know again movies
get made a lot of times with we're gonna
get into financing but it doesn't you
don't have to have all of your equity to
make a movie you want meka million are
moving you have a hundred thousand I was
working on a movie called Don McKay and
that's many years ago and the writer
came to me he had a hundred grand and
the you know I think the budge of the
movie we wouldn't do it for like three
million be here like a hundred grand and
we used that hundred grand to hire a
casting director Linda Paulo and she had
done the Rainmaker and like one of the
Jeepers Creepers movies at Virgin
Suicides like big movies we paid her
just a enough to get us one action get
me one actor and we took that hundred
grand
we had it an account so we could show it
to an agent show it it was real and we
made offers to I think we went to like
you know Patricia Clarkson Jeff Daniels
Holly Hunter which is like a bunch of
big and because we had money and we had
a legitimate casting director they read
it
we got real feedback like Holly said
this you know she really liked it but we
got a meeting with Marcia Gay Harden I
mean it was like you know three million
dollar movie this is right after sideway
he's gotta remember sideways right Paul
Giamatti at Thomas Henry Thomas
insurance I think the biggest thing in
town at that moment Thomas Haden Church
reads the script because I want to do
this and we had made a partial payer
play offer which is the payer play means
you get paid with the movie gets made or
not you know it's natural I'm a I made
you a pair of play offer means even if I
don't hit my targeted start that you get
paid oh yeah it works right that's payer
play but you don't have to have all of
the salary to make a pair play so I'm
say Thomas Haden Church I don't I don't
know
his feet wasn't let me say 150 grand we
go to his agent we say listen grimming a
partial payer play 50 grand
guaranteed just to say yes if we make
the movie get the other hundred yes 50
great say yes so you can leverage some
of that movie nice thing about Thomas
Hayden sure it's a very nice guy he
didn't take the money even though the he
said yes we didn't hit the start date
but he's like just let me know when you
have the money and the movie eventually
did get made by the way you can rent it
but it was and I wasn't actually I
didn't want to being a producer on it I
helped put the package together but
another person want to produce in the
film but but again we mount up
leveraging a hundred thousand and movie
got made for like three million bucks
and we got Thomas Haden Church and Keith
David a bunch of cool bike before we had
all the financing and that that guy
wanted getting to direct the movie as
well so he wanted to direct it and I
backed him as a director because he had
a strong vision for it he really had a
strong vision for it so when I say does
it have any financing attached you don't
have to have all your my I'll have a
million bucks yeah but do you have 50
grand you owe hundred grand you might be
able to turn that into something and and
then I guess let you know kind of you
know people were asking me you know what
would you know specifically what would I
look at if it doesn't have financing and
I said look you know again I work for
hire I don't really shop scripts but if
it had a really interesting log line and
it was a genre picture that I knew like
right now I could set up somewhere yeah
I probably take a look at it you know
hallmark again I keep using that example
because I have that relationship there
it's like somebody pushed me a really
good hallmark story like I know that Jim
walk that in at any point and it's a
quick I can set it up and here's the
thing about hallmark is they make
everything that they buy nothing goes
into development hell they're they don't
I think in like five years they like I
was talking to my friend they're like
yeah one time we didn't make the movie
because I have something happened but
like one time out of like they make a
contra movies a year so that's why I
like them so anyway look what do I look
for in a script that's that's you know
that's the answer so I wanted to get a
little bit into the indie producing the
development stage of actual of in some
indie producing what should I focus on
when trying to get a film off the ground
this is what people ask me so here's
some specific steps that I have had
success with and trying to get a film
off
first first and foremost script make
sure your script is strong spend time
and development and when I say spend
time in development I again I mean get
validation from someone who's in the
know not your friends not people who are
going to tell you it's great go to some
contest see what the feedback and pay
the little extra money to get the
feedback from the contest it's worth it
the contest 50 bucks and for the extra
five bucks or whatever you can get the
feedback or bigger name people or you
know where somebody's working in the
industry there's a lot of good coverage
services out there but get validation
from somebody who knows not your best
friend not your cousin you know somebody
knowledgeable and someone's gonna be
honest with you you know I had this this
kid Rocco out of New York reached out to
me through a mutual I think a former
client of mine and he had the script
called worth the fight and it was like a
boxing you know boxing movie you know
kind of rocky esque not really rocky but
you know kid is an underground street
fighter trying to support his younger
brother and sister and winds up getting
pulled in the world with legitimate
boxing which is so enactment to him he
has no idea you know and he's trying to
work his way up in that trying to take
his street fighting skills and work as
we have to the boxer to support his
family I'm like this is a cool script
like it means a lot it's rough and needs
work but I started you know working with
this kid and while they've developing
the script with him over six or seven
drafts and I don't like really and I
wound up doing the final polish on it
myself and you know we actually have a
company interested now it's you know
we'll see we'll see if it gets made but
a possible route to get in a picture
made and and you know it was like two
years we worked we worked together on
that script but but we got the script in
good shape now and it was it was worth
it spending the two years because I
think it actually has a chance
second seed capital that's the second
thing is see if you could put together a
little bit of money to launch
development how much it depends on the
scope and scale of your project but
again I gave you that example we got a
three million dollar picture maybe with
a hundred thousand dollars in seed
capital where do you get that kind of
money you know obviously the obvious
ones are friends and family again a lot
of people I know that's what they do
they go to friends and family
get enough friends and a family savings
credit and loans crowdfunding which I'm
not a fan of I'll get into crowdfunding
but but people do it
there is a company called film funding
la that helps you leverage I'm not
advocating for this one way or another
but I do know some people who have done
it
they help advocate you're like your
credit to help you get like a business
loan your personal credit to get a
business loan things like that so there
ways to do it but again you know it's
this is a business you know it's not
show show it's your business and you got
to invest in your business so sometimes
you know you got to put a little bit of
money where your mouth is and I am not
necessarily even saying invest your own
money into this but I'm saying you know
sometimes you have to go out and put you
know go reach out to some people might
believe in you and and get that I've
never put one dollar into a project ever
in my entire career never one dollar my
own money until they do a project but
I've grovelled III have growled
but that seed capital is kind of an
important piece of this because it
separates you from everybody else in
this town that don't want to do that you
know if you have a good script you have
a little bit of seed capital and again
maybe your movie can be done for 250,000
you'll have 25,000 stop 10% that's good
so look at the scale of it
third supporting materials so first and
I say supporting materials I mean your
breakdown and schedule and budget and
business plan if you're going to go out
and you're trying to put the project
together you need to have some sort of
package to show people so the first
thing is get to know your philosophy
like what's the what's your you're
producing philosophy I think you know
with me I'm always about trying to make
times look like dollars on screen that's
like my philosophy so you know it's some
people they want to put a bunch of money
into above the line I mean the biggest
actor I can and I'll spend whatever is
left I'll just make the film and which I
never find to be a good solution because
if you get that big actor they're gonna
come to set and be like what the hell is
this it's not gonna be the kind of
production they're used to but there's
different reducing philosophies you know
my philosophy is is
I you know try to put as much of that
money on the screen as possible
and you know it might be some people's
producing philosophy where I shoot ten
pages a day some people's producing
false we gonna shoot two pages a day but
you know I'm gonna shoot it in one lo
que
figure out your producing philosophy and
then from there you get you know if he
if you can't do it you hire libraries or
this kind of thing I do that that we you
know we break it down we do a schedule
we do a budget you put together business
plans so that the people you're talking
to understand your project and how
you're gonna leverage those assets you
have if you have a little bit of money
all of that's gonna be in your business
plan we already have a hundred thousand
out of our million fourth director most
the time cast is gonna want to know who
is directing if you have some credits
that's great if you don't you know it's
tough you're gonna have to yeah you have
to have a really strong script a really
strong vision and probably some money if
you're gonna get a name actor to sign on
and you have no dirt you know no real
feature directing credits so so getting
to a name director because cast is gonna
want to know again that's some somehow
if you have if you have some of that
seed capital that's something that you
can leverage to get to a director as
well and I'm not saying make them an
offer or not make them a pair play offer
I'm just saying you say to a director
I've got a hundred thousand my million
even a director I could director with
some decent credits there's there's
there's a lot of Directors in this town
that have credits that are looking for
work they see if you have some of your
money and a good script it's not as hard
as you think you have to go out and you
have to network don't be afraid to go in
on BB Pro and hit them up via email
because their emails probably you know
they might have an email on there or
whatever I'm not talking about the
biggest of the big guys who've you know
they've done a half dozen movies you
know somebody that you might trust if
it's not if it's not you but find a
director that that you know that has
some credits or that has some sort of
cachet or or you know it might might
appeal to to your cast maybe the genre
that they work in or the credits they
have but most casts gonna say well okay
who's directing or the agents going to
say who's directing so first you get
your you have your script second you
have your seed capital third you have
your supporting materials then you go
after your director
fifth is optional but I highly
recommended to try to get a distributor
on boards so many people wait till their
movies done to get a distributor and I
think it's a mistake and I say this to
most of my clients I say this must be
the people I work with get the
distributor on board early so many
people are afraid that the sugar is
going to usurp their creative authority
and so your project but it's a business
show business this is my old professor
Peter Guber used to say it's not show
show it's show business it is a business
and there's no other industry like
entertainment where people people forget
that they just look at the art and they
forget that it's a business so like you
think about this what other industry
would you spend millions of millions of
dollars setting up Rd sing up a
warehouse and doing manufacturing and
creating which I'm gonna make widgets
wait lots of widgets and then at the end
you boxes and boxes of wood you go ok
cool and I'm gonna figure out how to
sell these and where nobody nobody does
that you watch Shark Tank right they
come in and like how much does it cost
if it's two dollars and sixteen cents
like I have their numbers they know film
is the same it might also be an art
that's true but it's a business too and
so you need to remember those things so
getting a distributor on board they can
help you with story and script and say
like this is your ship that's fine but
you should have these elements they can
help you tailor it they can help you
figure out the case a problem with a lot
of films is you'll hear this from
distributors is by the time we get it
likes nothing else we can do we're stuck
with what we can't change the cast we
can't give many notes on the story or
the budget go to a distributor early
because they can tell you hey if we can
get the budget down a little bit we can
get these people you make these little
tweaks to the story thing we have a good
chance of selling this they can tell you
about positioning and marketing and
things you should be thinking about
early after all of those things then
it's time to go to the cast and you
think about and again so let's just use
this example of let's say you've got a
$250,000 movie and you've managed to put
together 50 grand with 50 grand you can
hire a decent casting director casting
directors worth their weight in gold
worth their weight in gold they've got
the relationships they know who's on the
upswing who's on the downswing
who is commanding what money they've got
relationships the agents manage I mean
they're really they are where they could
put together a list of ideas you never
thought of
and if you can get you put a little bit
that money toward a casting director and
you've got your distributor on board the
distributor can give you sales estimates
based on the names your casting director
has put together that you and your
casting director board so yeah your top
10 list let's say for the top you know
two or three roles you've got your top
ten wish list that you put together with
your casting director and distributor
that you have can say you know or sales
agent one of the other I think it's but
they can say here's here's the value
they bring in here is you know the kind
of money that we think we can get from
them obviously you know if they're you
know if they're viable for your size
project let's say you spent five grand a
year can you still got forty five
thousand dollars sitting there right to
make your partial player player offers
like I did with Thomas Haden Church and
it worked with Thomas adventure there's
worked a couple other times as well
Thomas is the biggest example all right
it worked so it's it's to me again
you're trying to get a film off the
ground and again sort of you know with
with name actors on let's say at least a
low six-figure budget screenplay seed
capital get your supporting materials
together director get a distributor and
then you go to your cast that's to me
that has been the order that has worked
most effectively because one sort of
plays off the other right I mean the
director wants to see the script a
Tribune wants it you know Calais I was
directing and you know the sugar helps
you get to the cast so there there's
rhyme and reason to all this it's all
this craziness I'm gonna pick up with
financing because this was obviously a
big question a lot of people had first
of all what do financier look for and
and again I told you guys I hate raising
money hate it I don't think I'm very
good at it but I just don't like it here
but I do know what financier is look for
it before and even though I hate it I
I'm often tangentially involved to some
degree when I say don't raise money I
don't raise suitcases full equity
suitcases full of cash I don't raise
that call these people unicorns people
have millions of dollars and are looking
to finance your movie I call them
unicorn
good luck finding a unicorn but here's
what finance here's look for three
things number one money in any good line
producer can tell you money in it's how
much do you need to make your film so
you have an idea of sort of the range in
the world
you know budgeting is not strictly
bottom-up it's not strictly top-down
meaning top-down meaning I want to do
this for two million but it's not
bottom-up either where someone people
have handed me a script before and
they've said how much it would cost to
make this film I'm Michael I don't know
it's Matt Damon leer movie because you
can have 10 million bucks to it if he is
I mean you know it bottom-up is building
the buds that you know as a line
producer billion budget top-down is you
know is sort of the the executive
producer or the senior producer saying
here's here's the kind of budget range
we want began to kind of meet in the
middle
but money in is how much is it gonna
cost it to make this thing I'm good you
know working with good line produce you
can figure that out
number two money out so meaning how am I
gonna make my money how much am I gonna
make my you know how much am I gonna
make when am I gonna make it
it's the ROI and how do you show money
out to to an investor this is your
business plan this is in that last
section we talked about your supporting
materials this is your business plan so
bankable cast even if they're not
attached yet at least have wish lists of
bankable cast how do you validate the
bank will cast remember we talked about
having a distributor or sales agent on
board to help validate because they can
put together foreign sales estimates
they can help you put together revenue
projections based on that cast wish list
even if you have no one attached but you
can say look here's our wish list we
want to go we're going for Kate
Beckinsale Jessica Biel Jessica Alba you
know whatever whoever these are the
people on our list and here's the kind
of numbers if we can get them here's who
our sales a what our sales agent says
that you know we can expect earn you
know based on their names so so showing
the investor how you're going to get
their money back you have a budget it's
a million bucks you feel you know based
on this budget you can get XYZ actor and
your sales agent or your distributors
saying you know we feel like we can do
this kind of business on this kind of
movie on this kind of budget with those
actors and that's you're showing your
investor a path to recoupment so you
show that in your you know there's a lot
of things that you can show in your
business plan just having the
distributor in your business plan the
investor knowing well the film's going
to get distributed at least
you have a distributor you put a profile
on the distributor in the business plan
yeah profile on your team so that they
know that you know that they're working
with
you know reputable filmmakers that you
guys actually know what you're doing so
you have a good profile on yourself and
your team all of these things are
they're important having the producer
profiles the director profile the cast
wish list they show the investor that
Wow okay I've got a viable path to get
my money back because I'm working with
professionals and for this budget this
distributor with thinks that with this
cast we can make xml back maybe showing
tax credits how you can leverage the tax
credits to help pay them back if you're
not using them as part of your budget
saying well we're gonna shoot in
Oklahoma it's 35% tax credit to add
another two percent if we if we have the
music done locally in Oklahoma you get
37% back just through Oklahoma of
whatever we spend there so if you guys
spend a million bucks there there's
three hundred seventy thousand dollars
there's also federal tax credit programs
it used to be called 181 C and now it's
called something else but where
investors can leverage and write-off
like 100% of their investment is passive
income and there's been some changes to
it I don't know all the details of it
but but but having those kind of things
in your business plan it's saying look
right off the bat through tax credits
and through this this is show them how
they're going to get a return once once
you do that the third thing what's
really going to differentiate you got to
think about you got show the money and
show the money out the third thing is
why you is you know what makes you and
your story a better investment than the
other ten business plans sitting there
you got ten other pictures with ten
other budgets ten other biz to know
their business plans that all are
showing money and money out but why you
will make you different if I'm gonna
give you a million bucks I got a see
maybe it's sunny and maybe it's the
stories really topical wow this has to
be told right now
you know I'm working with with a guy
right now we've got this this really
cool head like I'm so excited about this
and he's out putting the money together
I like I said I'm not I'm not doing that
part but but about this family who gets
this smart home device like a Google
home like Amazon Alexa like one of those
kinda nice to help to to their kids
because they try to get their kids in
this private school and they're having
trouble to during the kids and the kids
speak in this sort of like the made-up
language when they don't want the
parents know what they're saying the
parents hate it and they bring home this
Alexa type thing called Lee - and the
the kids hate it at first but then the
Lee - teaches itself their language and
starts to befriend them and all of a
sudden like they you know they they
start ingratiate themselves you know
into their lives and they start doing
better it starts tutoring them but then
it starts that this box starts having
the kids push boundaries and it starts
to like take over like telling the
parents what to do and pushing
boundaries and find the parents like
okay enough is enough and they get rid
of it and then the kids at this point
they're like no because they love this
thing they secretly get another one and
the kids in the box start plotting to
take out the parents I can't a Mike this
is such a read the script I'm like this
is one of the cool with scripts I have
read this a long time like the pitch was
so good a lot of times you read the
script like oh it's not as good as the
pitch unfortunately but this script
really was and I'm like but we need to
make this it's so topical right now we
can scare the out of people with
the home the goal you know this is a
smart home thing is so big right now so
that's an example of like why you want
that would separate if I had a pile of
10 business plans and I saw that it
because it was so topical and relevant a
guy this separate thing about what might
separate you and what might get someone
excited but those are the three things
investors look for even if they don't
know they're looking for them that's
what they're looking for they're looking
for the money at how much money in how
much do you need money out how am I
gonna get my money back and how much am
I gonna get back and when am I gonna get
back that's your business plan work with
your sales agent put put those numbers
together cast wish list put your
profiles together on your team show them
that you're working they're working with
a good team and why you why is this
story got to be done now what makes you
different and don't just say I'm
passionate everybody's gonna say that
you got to really find a real angle like
the one I just I gave I gave you a
specific this is an example for that
reason finding out something that's sort
of that that's an angle that's gonna
excite them and knowing who your
financier is you know if you know your
financier that might help you figure out
the angle if you know what they're in
two types of financing people were
asking you like well you know so what
types of financing or are out there
because most people anything of
financing they think of private equity
they just think about equity equity is
is your suitcase full of cash and you're
always going to need at least a little
bit of equity
I mean I'm hard pressed to find many
independent movies that got made without
at least some equity the and the equity
is the equity investor is you know
they're the ones that are gonna get
repaid based on the revenues of the film
what's a standard equity deal usually
about a hundred and twenty percent
return to your investor so if you guys
are offering your invest or something
it's usually a hundred twenty percent
first out so saying you know give me a
million bucks you're gonna get paid 1.2
back before anybody else gets paid
assuming that they're the only investor
if there's multiple investors then you
can split it what they call pro rata
pair pursue which means you know if you
put in fifty percent you put in 50
percent you're gonna get forty percent
back and you're gonna get 50 percent
back at the same time every dollar comes
in you get 50 and you get 50 it's called
pro rata means equal proportion power
pursue means at the same time so 120
percent and then anywhere from 30 to 50
percent thereafter so you know you say
after you make your hundred twenty
percent you're gonna get thirty five
percent of everything they're after and
then I'm gonna get sixty five percent
that would be it
think of semi standard private equity
deal but private equity is not the only
type of thing suitcases full of cash are
not the only type of financing there's
debt equity so that's cash in the form
of a loan I try to stay away from cash
in the form of a loan whenever I can
because you have to pay that back unless
you know how you're gonna pay it back so
if you have like a minimum guarantee or
negative pick-up deal from a studio okay
you know my negative pickup deals like
where the studio says we'll buy the film
once you delivered as long as you meet
the criterias of the contract like as
long as it's a stand you have grade a
quality theatrical quality motion
picture with these actors at this budget
level and you know whatever as long as
you meet the criteria when you deliver
the film they buy it that contract is
bankable so yeah maybe you take out a
loan on that contract but as long as you
I wouldn't I kind of stay away from debt
equity on this
have something bankable like that bridge
loans which are short-term loans to help
you get from one stage to the next that
would be an example of debt equity you
know you just need a short-term cash
infusion to help you get to some other
stage of financing but debt equity is
another type of financing tax credits
also tax credits are either you know
there's usually some sort of rebate or
incentive offered by the state upon
completion of the film but how can you
use that to make the film well if you
provisionally get accepted for a tax
credit you can take that paperwork
typically in Bank it you can go to an
entertainment bank and they'll lend
against it not a dollar for dollar but
like maybe 82 cents on the dollar or
something so if the state of Oklahoma as
an example says for your 370,000 say
yeah you know you're in spending you're
in spend a million bucks here you're
gonna get three hundred seventy thousand
Bank back you might be able to go to a
bank and get two hundred ninety thousand
or something off of that three hundred
or whenever whatever that number winds
up being eighty percent foreign
pre-sales you know that's where you sell
the film to to a foreign territory
before the films made again bankable so
if your sales agent you have let's say
you have Jessica Alba and Jessica Biel
starring in a movie and you you have
your sales agent aboard they can take it
to England and they pre sale the movie
at you know or whatever they go to can
and they pre sell it you can take that
contract and you can bank it go to a
bank and you get a 82 cents on the
dollar or whatever depends on who buys
it I mean it has to be a legitimate
company but it's a legitimate foreign
buyer body that you can bank that
contract gap financing not as big now
used to be big gap financing is where a
bank comes in and invests usually it's
like the last 20% if you have 80 percent
and you're looking for that last 20 gap
financing as a bank coming in and saying
we'll put up the 20
but it has to be against some unsold
foreign territories you have to have
some territories that haven't been sold
yet they want to see that you've sold a
couple so they know it's viable but then
you know that the project's viable so
maybe your sales agent has sold England
but Japan is still available and
Australia is still available and Latin
America is still available and France is
still available so that needs to be
against some you know some unsold
foreign territory the thing about thing
about Gap is it's it's really expensive
and it gets paid back first so if you
have an equity investor they have to sit
behind the bank so it's it's tough you
know so you might have a guy he's
putting up eight hundred thousand a year
million but he doesn't want to sit
behind the bank so bank says we'll put
the other two hundred thousand but we
get paid back first and at a very high
fee that's gap financing so gap gap can
be tough but if your financier is on
board was sitting behind the bank and
waiting for the bank then you know it's
it's why it's it's viable but it's you
got to have a sales agent you got to
have at least one or two territories
sold and then the rest of the world open
for them to leverage against then
there's super gap which another type of
financing where if you have let's say
seventy percent of your financing and
the bank comes in with the other twenty
now you've got ninety Super gap
financier will come in with another ten
they'll sit right behind the bank but in
front of your equity investor so the gap
gets paid back first at a high premium
the super gap gets paid back next at a
high premium and then your equity
investors so especially these levels of
financing if you guys wanted to look up
specific gap or super gap finance here's
you could probably google it super get
financing I'm sure links will come up to
companies that do super gap and gap
financing gaps mostly Bank but there's
there's there's companies that do super
gap I'm gonna graph Grovner Park still
does it but there were there companies
that do super gap so if you're kind of
almost there with your equity well I'm
trying to tell you guys is you don't
need to have a suitcase full of money to
cover your entire budget there's other
ways to do it
deferments I try to stay away from
deferments I told well film well and I
did together I told will I don't do any
deferment deferments and back-end are
two things people often confuse how many
times I've talked to people to go oh
well ya know I might not have to pay
them their pays deferred
like that's something you ought to pay I
means you just have to pay you have to
pay them but later deferments are you
know my editor is going to get paid six
months real incentive right now we still
have six months you have to pay him as
opposed to back-end which is people
agreeing to be paid contingent on the
film's revenues that's back-end so it's
like oh yeah I'm gonna get you know I'm
gonna pay back end if a movie makes
money
that's not deferment deferment is you're
getting paid but later when you're
getting a pain in six months it comes
due it's time to pay the piper so I
either I pay you now or your pity or
you're getting back in but I don't I
don't like to do deferment so I teeth of
pay people I have the budget I'm gonna
pay you now or it's more it's straight
back in grants are another way
especially if any you guys are
documentary filmmakers a lot of grants
what's the difference between grants and
equity grants there's no obligation to
pay back you know a private equity
investment you don't have to pay them
back either but there they want their
money back grants it's like here's the
money
so like the ID a the International
Documentary Association unscripted film
labs and some of the companies we can
find phone documentary grants a lot of
them they often come with a lot of rules
like you have to have already shot ten
minutes or has to be within this subject
matter we're only taking projects
between April and May but look into
grants and could often be sort of offset
maybe some other financing that you
already have in kind contributions so
those are donations you know in kind
will count if it's a significant enough
to mean something in your budget so if
you're doing a million dollar film and
somebody donate something that's 50
grand that's five percent your budget
that's that's worth I mean if it's a
budget line item but it's being donated
it still counts same as if it was cash
so in-kind is important sometimes
locations get your whole location
donated in-kind that's a budget line
item that counts brand integration and
product placement there's a lot of
companies out there like be en brand
Entertainment Network there's another
Hollywood branded there's a lot of these
that you can reach out to especially if
you have a little bit going for you very
have an act
or maybe just have a really solid
project that you think I worked the
fight I reached out to Everlast I just
started talking to Everlast I have a
relationship now with the guy he's like
yeah we could give you a whole bunch of
product to put in the movie am i cool no
like no talking to the head of brand
integration their product placement
branding Gration a little bit different
product placements like this is just
like sort of sitting here it's like a
coke bottle in the shot the product
placement brand integration is it's
being used by the actor it's integrated
into the story most the brands one brand
integration they actually want George
Clooney drinking the coke and talking
about it castaway FedEx that's a good
example of brand integration as opposed
to prop placements it's a gratuitous oh
right in the background the coca-cola
sign oh and sometimes brands will pay
money to have their product in your in
your project depending on the size of
the star of the scope and scale of the
project so just came back to form
pre-sales for a second someone
specifically asked me how do they work
how to form pre-sales work and it's
really not that complicated so you need
to get a foreign sales agent there's a
lot of them out there Hyde Park and
Arclight and these are you know examples
of sales agents there's big ones they're
small as those are some of the big ones
basically you know you take your project
to a sales agent again I think as early
as you possibly can I'm a big fan of
getting distributors and sales agents on
board as early as possible they might
not be if they're really big they might
not be interested unless you have some
name actors but there's a lot of small
to medium sized ones that I think you
probably could get get interest from if
you have a you know a solid script maybe
it's based on a really interesting story
or something but but you go to a sales
agent say look you know I'm putting this
film together I've got some seed capital
what have you you might be able to get
them to agree to sign on but they
probably won't be able to pre-sell
anything unless you have a net you have
an actor on board that's what everybody
wants is you know what are the factors
to Dupre selling cast number ones cast
number two is cast and number three is
cast that's with a cast cast cast that's
what they want who's in it then I would
say fourth is genre
with the genre oh so I got dolph
lundgren Oh awesome great it's an action
movie uh that's a romantic comedy oh no
sorry
you know or you know vice versa
you know I've got Julia Roberts oh cool
but it's a martial arts movie oh okay
like it's the right actor in the right
right movie genre and then probably so
I'd say after first then genre then
budget the budget for that project and
then maybe director if it's a director
driven project and the directors big
enough that can have an effect so you
get the sales agent on board to do a
contract with the sales agent you hire
them and in your contract so the
question that this this subscriber asked
was like who does the negotiation for
the the the deal and so basically we
when you hire foreign sales agent you do
a contract with them that lays out all
the parameters for your arrangement and
it will tell you how much leeway they
have so I might say any deal up to X
amount they can just close that deal on
their own they don't have to ask you as
the producer is okay if we close this
deal with you know Australia for $20,000
they can just do it so they whatever the
parameters are it's going to be in that
contract and then you know so but with
input from the producer the sales agent
goes to the foreign you know to the
markets to AFM can Venice Berlin and
they try to sell your movie based on the
package and that's it they come back to
you say hey we sold three territories
over there and if you want to maybe Bank
those you can but it's it's really
that's you know it's really not that
complicated approach the foreign sales
agent with your project and if they like
the project and you do a contract with
them and they they go to work
I also got he asked a lot about
crowdfunding I never mentioned this to
Karen D before I'm not a fan of
crowdfunding I really don't like it for
films and I'm not it's not that I'm not
a fan of crowdfunding I'm not a fan of
crowdfunding films and for there's three
basic reasons that I'm not a fan of
crowdfunding number one I feel like it
works great for like sort of new
innovative products technology products
things like that things people can hold
and touch films are you know so many
films out there people like oh that's
cool but you know what I'll see it when
it you know it comes that's it's tougher
than like this create new innovative
thing that people want to be a part of
and they're gonna get to hold it and
touch it so I feel like if you look at
what does well on crowdfunding platforms
it's usually tech stuff and innovative
new projects not so much film
and when I say when I say not films not
films from a stranger's perspective
strangers don't typically because I'm
miles don't go yeah I got an investment
but they but tech products they do to is
you know you just wind up hitting this
you wound up hitting up the same friends
and family you could have just hit up
directly that's what you want I'm doing
I'm on I'm on Kickstarter give me you
know give me money
can just hit them up directly now you
have to spend time you know putting
together these whatever you promised
they would do taking away all your time
from actually putting the film together
because you up oh they were level five
and I've got to do this I've got to give
them a copy of the poster I cop it and
just I think it's a distraction
and you want to putting up the same
people you could have gone to directly
had third if you wanted to giving away
five percent of your budget so if you
raised a hundred grand and you need that
hundred grand to make your movie you
just keep five thousand dollars to
Kickstarter IndieGoGo you can use to
make your movie could have gone to those
people anyway directly and you didn't
have to give a five percent to those
platforms I have not seen a lot of there
might be some people watch this video no
he doesn't know he's talking about I
raised money on them maybe they did I'm
just telling you from me I didn't I
don't I haven't had success with it and
those are the reasons I don't like it
one quick important lesson I'm gonna end
the financing session because I want to
keep it going but but is guys children
have raising money is raising money is
raising money no matter how much money
it is it's hard it's the same raising
two hundred two thousand raising two and
a half million a lot of mistake a lot of
filmmakers do is they they try to cut
their budgets way down in
of getting attracting an investor easier
and it doesn't work that way
a lot of investors they might look at
and go 250,000 well how am I gonna make
my money back can't make a good movie
that way I'd rather give you a million
to make a move a bigger name actor I
actually have a chance to get my money
back making it for a low-budget does not
necessarily mean that it's gonna be
easier to fund in many ways sometimes
it's harder to fund but raising money is
it's all relative there might be more
people out there with 250,000 and 25
million there that might be true but
it's no easier to get them to part with
their money
it's all relative you stuff to convince
that person it apart from it's tough so
don't think that you need to cut your
budget way down to try to try to get
your money that's not necessarily always
the best Avenue I want to get a little
bit into the product production stage
because I got the question how to how do
I produce cost-effectively and you know
it's such a broad question because
that's always going to depend on the
needs of your production and the size of
your budget but again like I told you
guys I always try to make times look
like dollars on screen so a couple
things you know number one hire for
talent hire for talent hire hire people
that are better at what you what they do
then you are and what they do and listen
to those people listen to people who are
experts I've sat with people well you
know I'll tell people listen I'm gonna
I'm gonna I'm gonna give you three
things I want to tell you the results I
want I'm gonna tell you when I want it
I'm gonna tell you what I'm gonna give
you to get that result you know say you
the count you're my DP here's our budget
here's the camera I'm gonna give you
here's what I want it to look like I
want you to make sure this director's
taken care of and we need to have this
thing shot on schedule above all
whatever okay great go do it I hired you
cuz you know more about shooting than I
know about shooting that's why I hired
you so hire for talent listen you're
people there are a lot of there are a
lot of good people in this town
especially in Los Angeles London is the
competition is stiff you know as people
are trying to you know outgun each other
they're trying to get the jobs there's a
lot of people looking for work so you
can find good talent for a reasonable
cost here go to Nashville I shot
musically is in Nashville and they all
expect like commercial level rates for
Indies
people you get pay 200 a day here and
they want 400 a day there because that's
what they're used to you know there's
always a few small you know there's like
you know the crew members are you know
it's like not as many crew there's so
many crews here yeah have a hundred
productions going on in LA and you
always find a crew you know always find
it clean so high over talent and pay
your people feed your people
that's it'll show on screen and you've
heard that before but it's true it's one
of those truisms it will show on screen
feed them well hire for talent pay him
well listen to them on films under a
million bucks go for the non-union crew
but use sag actors always use sag actors
always it you can cut around some bad
art department here there or you know
badshah whatever but like your actors
man they're always bad acting will kill
that film you know the script and the
acting one thing I've even even on I've
done the lowest budget film I've ever
done it's about a hundred hundred
thousand narrative and even now you sag
actors you can get good sag actors say
ultra-low budget scale is 125 bucks and
you know you're an actor right under 25
bucks a day 825 for 8 so you can get
good act it's worth it
non-union crew no problem there's a lot
of good solid skilled non-union crew if
you're a million bucks is like sort of
that line where the union starts
sniffing you out but if you're under a
million bucks you can get away with it
but always I sag I always use that guy
and then you know again again part of
producing cost-effectively just
negotiate great deals on on gear
locations
you know vehicles resources things like
that those kind of below-the-line things
there's so much competition here you can
if somebody doesn't want to give you the
rate that you want you like our I'll go
down the street to the next guy I mean
there's so many options here so don't be
afraid to negotiate but but in terms of
reducing cost effectively I think that
that's sort of is there's no there's no
big dark secret that's really when it
comes down to making the most of a small
crew you know make sure your stories
contained enough if you have a small
crew if you don't have a lot of
resources make sure your stories
contained enough to be effectively
pulled off in
frame and that doesn't mean this is
another hand drives me nuts
it's it can all be done in a single
location so doesn't mean it's gonna be
cheap
I shot a whole movie called New York
Christmas in the Biltmore Hotel and it
was an indie film it still caught it so
is running me twenty five hundred three
grand a day just for the hotel rooms
because it's the Biltmore and it had to
be as high-end hotel you know and for an
indie film it was a lot of money you
know so but we never moved we the whole
thing was in that hotel but it was one
expensive location so one location does
not mean cheaper it could save you time
because you don't have to transport and
you don't have to get trucks and stuff
like that depending on on the size of
the film but when I say contained I just
mean you look at the script you go hey
do the logistics warrant can I keep the
budget down because these logistics
aren't you know kind of crazy but it
doesn't necessarily have to meet a
single location and figure out maybe
what here's another way to make the most
of a small crew and be effective is
figure out maybe what positions can be
combined and cut for example now when I
say what positions can be cut the first
thing I tell you is do not cut your
script supervisor don't do it don't do
it
you might say oh we can do it without it
no you can't and more pointing your
editor can don't cut your script
supervisor you're welcome script
supervisors but there are some so there
are some areas that you can that you can
combine for example like you know maybe
your second AC or your editor can do
your di t or if it just because a data
management not true di T where they're
doing color correction on set but data
management maybe you know your I have a
second ad who want smaller films when
we're doing like ultra low or low
modified look he coordinates for me okay
if I'm you P I mean we'll sort of share
coordinated news I don't have to hire a
separate coordinator at second ad steps
up and we kind of do the coordinating
maybe if it's small enough you have a PA
that can do crafty my wife does craft
services kill me if I said hire PA to do
crafty but depending on the budget it's
kind of like look here's the shopping
list just go get this stuff there's
there's there's there's roles that can
be combined that's another way to be
effective interns can you hire some
interns when I say hire interns I mean
from a school where they're getting
credit because you want them to show up
remember you get
pay for don't say let me use my friends
for these five rolls don't do it go do
LS you're paying them don't do unless
you're paying them but interns they're
getting paid with credits so so I mean
true interns you know yeah I've used
production designers that have also done
the set dressing you know they have a
prop master and they have some art
department assistant but they'll also do
that they'll do the design staff our
direction and they'll also do the set
dressing
so you can combine roles and here's the
thing to a lot people I don't think I
could pay my crew a lot you know hiring
crew and you don't have to pay them a
lot
ellee's competitive again there's lots
of talented people that want experience
you know if it's low budget enough maybe
pay cash if you can and people five an
unemployment I didn't say that but they
do what they got to do you know but if
you treat everybody well a lot of times
what I'll do is I'll take like um I
don't know like a set decorator and I'll
get me a chance to be an art director
get me a chance to step up you know what
I mean
or secondary seek its chance to first or
whatever and he really was into work for
the lower budget say look I'd love to
pay you more but it's something he gets
200 a day you know the Assisting is 175
second assist gets 150 that's the rates
but I might hire up I'll give you a
chance to prove yourself because I
believe in I know hey you've been a prop
master for three years I know I'm sure
yeah I believe you can art direct I've
seen your vision the director likes you
let's give it a let's give it a go and
they're gonna work doubly hard for let
look for less money they're gonna work
doubly hard cuz they want to prove
themselves instead of getting that guy's
like oh I've got I've got this got my
leg budget film he was the production
designer on rocky that could be a
problem when he's like I'm not used to
working in these conditions it's
sometimes better to get that guy who
wants to take a step up they will work
twice as hard for you you know dealing
with talent you know was it trust your
director in your casting director to
handle anything below a star role as a
producer because I'm talking to above
the line people here you guys are
producers writers as a producer trust
your kit you're casting directing your
director to handle anybody under a star
role I get head shots or people saying
god you know I'd love a small role in
this someone I just don't
but I don't deal with the small rules I
make offers to the names and the
director cash you have to do the day
players and do that I don't even you
know will and I do I think I popped in
for the casting like how they going but
you know other than stars I don't you
know because as a producer those are the
people that are gonna help me sell the
film and that's the producers that's
really a pretty serious responsibility
help bring on the casting director to do
that small smaller stuff and get the
stars somebody asked me about dropping
talent for someone else yeah it happens
like you have your friend attached and
yeah I got a chance to get the movie
made but you got to drop your friend and
put Billy Bob Thornton and what do you
do hopefully your friend understands
that you know you got to get the movie
made
bottom line nobody's locked until
there's a contract do you know contract
with your friend because if you don't
you mean like hey friend sorry but maybe
there's maybe there's a consolation
prize maybe some compensation or another
smaller role but people have to
understand you've got what did I say the
beginning get the picture made and your
friend should understand that so I
wanted me to mentioned distribution
again I've said this a bunch but get a
distributor involved early and often
again they can be your best friend you
still own the project they don't they're
not going to take the project away from
you they're going to give you a lot of
valuable advice you know again on
casting and the script and budgeting
marketing and release strategy all these
kind of things that you need to think
about as a producer and I said this is a
business and it's a team effort and
distributors it can be another part of
your team just at the camera op just
like the sound mixer just like the other
let's see what else we got
considering your audience and how to
reach them yeah I mean that's this is
sort of sort of basic but as a producer
you need to know your audiences who are
they where are they and how will they
see the film and not just how will they
see it so what will cost to reach them
so you as a producer again just remember
it's not just production money you're
dealing with it's P&A money printing
advertising money you need five million
bucks to get the random guy walking down
the street here in Vineland 5 million
minimum to get that guy's attention
billboards bus shelters minimum of five
just as a rule of thumb
where do you find PNA funds distributors
sometimes there's dedicated PNA
investors this is now this I'm kind of
moving forward little bit assuming you
have your movie money to make your movie
but production funds aren't always all
you need so so PNA for there's some some
investors that just put up PNA funds
prints and advertising funds maybe your
original investor if he really believes
in the film goes well you know put up a
little bit more put of a million bucks
for this but I'll put another hundred
thousand bucks or whatever for PNA tax
credits could use the tax credit money
for PNA if that's you know that's not
part of your recruitment strategy for
your investor maybe you can use the tax
credit money for DNA and then platforms
think about you know in terms of
reaching your audience what platforms is
you know with this play on yes there's
theaters everybody wants that they has
the Holy Grail as the theaters right but
there's a vods s bought Evod you know
the vod's right video on demand Avon is
advertising based video on demand that's
like your YouTube your daily motion
we're trying to watch it then there's
annoying a heads pop up and gets it
through them and then all right your s
pod which is you know your Netflix and
Amazon's where you pay the monthly TiVo
transactional where you pay each for
each project you know that's like your
iTunes and also Amazon's and then you
get you know dvd/blu-ray pay TV premium
cable you know standard cable broadcast
TV mobile you think about all the places
that that your project can play this
should go in your business plan it's
also pod your strategy with your
investor it's like here's where we see
it playing these are all things that
producers should be thinking about early
on and your marketing also things you
should be thinking about early on
there's traditional marketing trailers
TV spots key art you know your posters
there's your festival strategy there's
your social media there's publicity and
publicity breaks down in the field
publicity and national publicity field
as local national was right big
promotions can be tying promotions to
give aways products and there are
specific people you can bring on to
handle a lot of these things on the film
that will and I did and it wasn't right
it wasn't a huge film but we had a
social media manager right we had a PR
company to do publicity not a big film
low six figures but it was low six
figures
but we had a team I did the traditional
marketing myself because I have
experience with it I did festivals but
we have brought on a team we brought on
a social media person we brought on a PR
person it was and there's good people
out there again just like the rest of
your crew that want to work maybe
they'll do it for a flat fee which i
think is what we did I don't know you
know we had some sort of some sort of
good deal so these are all things my
point is these are all things you'd be
thinking about early too
not when the film is done a few
miscellaneous things I want to I want to
make sure we have time for the Q&A if
you guys have questions but just a few
random sort of miscellaneous things
people that didn't really fit into the
outline but I wanted to try to address
networking someone was asking has
in-person networking been totally
replaced by social media
no it hasn't you think of the ladder
social media has a tool to help with the
former I got on Facebook back in like oh
nine just just to facilitate sort of
meetings with people where I can get
face-to-face with them but it's not a
replacement you know it's it's just
another tool in the toolbox you will
always need face to face networking
always there's something about seeing
someone face to face and talk to them
would this be the same if you guys were
at home you know listening to a podcast
watching that's not the same as being in
the room right somebody asked I thought
this was really funny real nobodies
versus fake somebody's who breaks it
easier
I actually had to think about that one
for a little bit you know kind of my
answer was depends on what area of the
business actually sort of this like
next-gen video networks I think like
YouTube red and machinima and maker and
it might be quoting these sort of like
social media celebs but I think as a
general rule in my opinion real talent
ultimately gets noticed so you know sort
of the real nobodies maybe if they say
when they say nobody's meaning they're
you know they're not knowing yet if you
have real talent you're gonna get you'll
get discovered I truly believe that if
you really have talent
and real town can be can be can be honed
into a skill you know you can take town
you can create a skill from Tallinn
somebody asked about going from YouTube
to features and the site wife taught
Elmo I ins and what I would tell you
guys is telling stories is telling
stories is telling stories and YouTube
is just a format to platform it whether
it's five minutes or a hundred five
minutes telling a story I've done
commercials sometimes telling of sorry
30 seconds is harder than telling a
story in three hours
yeah a lot of times in many ways there's
really no great mystery and it's the
same thing even on YouTube you know it's
like it you have to speak to your
audience you know have some good
material interesting characters know
your audience give them value I mean it
really comes down to it there's no big
mystery there but some people would say
well but there's differences in
mechanics I'm just producing low YouTube
videos I don't know about the big
feature world or vice versa I'm used to
features I don't understand the YouTube
world surround yourself by a strong team
that knows that world that's that's what
it comes down to if you're moving from
YouTube to features and you're a
director that's fine just hire strong
line producer strong you PM 80s DP
editor production designer hire people I
know that world you know you know will
and I we're doing the film that we did
together his original idea for a DP had
never done any features never shot a
feature this was wills first feature I
was like you know the thing is yeah I
respect hey look if you you love this
guy great but problem is you know you
got to dance partners and neither of you
were experienced dancers yet if one of
you should dance you know how to dance
first
and so I set them up on a bunch of
meetings with you know with and like
it's like the first or second meeting
ash met with ash who had shots movie
called ninja apocalypse for me before
and well it's like done I love ash done
and now like you guys are boys I mean
now it's like you know so but
surrounding yourself with the team that
understands that world some people asked
me to recommend a few resources I know
we had just been talking about UCLA
Extension if you don't want to go to
school but you want to like get UCLA's
awesome because the professors there are
working professionals I am NOT a fan of
academics I've said this as well people
that spend their entire time in academia
or to me are too disconnected
UCLA has working professionals to come
teach the classes it's like my marketing
professor at UCLA was the head of all of
marketing for DreamWorks like Steven
Spielberg was our boss all of marketing
she and she came a ton of class for
three hours awesome these people teach
the extension classes too you don't have
to just enroll in the class you don't
have to get admitted to you see how it's
just a night class or whatever you can
so that's one thing um I am DB Pro we
should have an IMDB pro account Box
Office Mojo the numbers those are free
so for your business plan Box Office
Mojo the numbers IMDB pros we can get a
lot of good information on what films
made for your business plan what they
cost to make what they made on home
entertainment like DVD streaming if
you're looking to option scripts
blacklist Inc tip specs scout those are
all decent sites for finding scripts
without a box good for film festivals if
you're looking for film festivals that's
what I used on on our project I was
doing the festival strategy all the
research I did without a box if you're
looking for for work or crew staff me up
Mandy I think Mandy has like a paid
feature in a non paid feature so if you
want good crew you probably do the paid
one showbiz labor guide that's online
now and I think it's free for everybody
it's a little secret for us line
producers I don't tell a lot of people
that but I guess everybody knows cats
down the bag now but I think it's a
media distributors I forget a company it
is but look up showbiz labor guide you
can find rates for all the union crews
and things like that movie magic
you've got screenwriting
writing software you got the budgeting
software you've got the scheduling
software final draft of course
screenwriting and one knows point zero
slash I think they called hot budget now
it was point zero and I was the version
I have is still point zero but I think
it's called hot budget now it's a
budgeting software that's Excel based
you guys don't have to go spend a lot of
money on movie magic it's cool about hot
budget slash point zero whenever it's
called now is anybody can open it so
your investor can open if they don't
have to get movie magic you want to make
a PDF of it they can open it and it
gives you an actual column you can track
your actual what you're actually
spending versus your estimates movie
Mattie doesn't let you put actuals in
why because entertainment partners want
you to buy Vista their accounting
software that's why so on a really low
budget like hot budget point zero is it
good it was originally made for the AICP
for commercials commercials of music
videos but I started using it for
low-budget films like I don't need movie
magic it's overkill for a three hundred
thousand dollar film a few books that I
like creative producing A to Z it's a
good one
Merl schribman who was a professor of
mine UCLA one of my mentors at UCLA he
wrote that book really good book
producer to producer step step by step
guide to low-budget independent film
producing is a good one the independent
film producer Survival Guide also good
one a lot of good resources and then for
script you know you have screenplay by
Syd field story by Robert McKee they're
sort of like the gibbons like people
know about those and I stand by those I
mean they're they're obviously really
solid works and then in terms of a
production software studio plus studio
and then the plus symbol by casting crew
which is the payroll company is a really
it's really good for like managing
production workflow we have a big enough
budget you know it's you know if you're
really small might be overkill but
managing production workflow storage
distribution collaboration of you know
forms and schedules and things it's
let's everybody sort of access in
real-time updates and things you're not
like can hand out new pages and all this
so studio plus and then you know mentor
ships you guys were asking about earlier
somebody asked me you know do they
provide value and I mean look again
that's why I do that's why I do this I
enjoy it I enjoy helping people I enjoy
you know inspiring people and if
you guys get even any kernel of usable
information from this then I feel like
this was worth it for me
so if you're gonna find like a
one-on-one mentor again I mentor people
in the PGA just make sure that that
mentors is right for you based on your
goals based on what you want to do I do
some research on them and mentors are
available you know through the guilds
through University's film labs private
organizations you can find there's
there's places to find mentors I've been
mentored as well like I said a UCLA I
had a mentor at the PGA when I first
went in there Jerry Joey McFarland who
produced wolf of wallstreet and a couple
other couple other things I signed up to
be a mentee and then I started mentoring
other people so you know but you have
some of these like private organizations
that have specific mandate it's like
women in film or diversity or whatever
that you know may have mentorship so I'm
a fan and I think they're worth looking
into you never know where that
relationship that's gonna help your film
get going will come from and then the
last the very last point the state of
the industry somebody asked I save this
for last on purpose is the business
getting tougher each day and the answer
is no one would guess what the answer is
my answers are so all over the place I
just want to know if anybody has has an
idea of what I'm gonna say my answer is
not necessarily not yes or no it's not
necessarily some things are definitely
easier you're living at a time where
you've got prosumer technology like
final cut or what's Adobe Premiere
whatever the hutt they have a final cuts
not the thing now now it's Adobe or avid
or whatever but you've got these red
cameras and Ares like you got ya
understand like when the Coen brothers
made Blood Simple like they didn't have
all this stuff they had like they had to
get the same big movie cameras and 35
millimeter film that like the studio's
had right you've accessed this prosumer
technology now and numerous platforms
like YouTube and Vimeo and places to
display your work festivals so many
festivals now and all of this the
technology and accessibility is lowered
costs so for the indie world in many
ways it's much easier bigger name stars
and doing independent films so I thought
for the indie world I think things have
gotten easier
easy but it's gotten easier than it was
at the nasan stages of the indie
movement right the studio system is a
bit different it's a whole different
animal
I think that's gotten harder because
when I started the business maybe there
were seven studios no there's like five
mg I'm a sort of a studio and you know
Disney just ate up Fox and it was like
five
it's basically like Disney slash Fox's
one paramount Universal Warner Brothers
and Sony and they used to make like 20
22 films a year now I think Disney last
year may 12 so if less Studios making
less films and the type of films they're
making are very focused so they're
making a lot of franchise pictures paste
on comic books and there's like this
sort of gap there's no middle class in
films anymore right it's just sort of
like big-budget spider-man 12 and then
there's right and then there's like the
sort of 20 million dollar film that
George Clooney is like slumming in or
whatever but it's awards caliber right
so so you know for those 50 million
dollar like they're not being made why
in 70s into the 80s you had people
running studios that loved to making
movies you had this renaissance in the
70s love story was the movie that saved
paramount right love story Exorcist
Godfather you people Ike Robert Evans
running the studio with creatives they
were he was an actor you know and into
the 80s and I was like the generation I
that was the era of the my era and they
could tell movies were fun they love
making these now you know you have is
this true you have CPAs and lawyers and
they're running them number crunchers
are running the studios that's part of
the difference so I think the studio
world has gotten harder and that's part
of reason I love the indie world and I
like where I am and that's and that's
why I love what I do and my father
followed grandpa's advice and stuck in
that world and love what I do and that's
and that's all she wrote so hopefully
there's some good information there for
you guys yeah it was a lot to you
probably but I want to actually you know
guy one day at least give you guys some
specifics and not just platitudes like
you can do it of course you know you can
do it you know while you're here so you
guys say
but you guys have any questions based on
anything here yeah I'm just wondering
are there screenwriting managers people
that will help you brought in writing
screenplay
absolutely I saw I think I think again
with UCLA Extension - you're gonna have
access to a lot of that sort of that
internally without having to enroll as a
student I think that's probably a good
place to start I don't know if the WGA
has a program like that
I'm as intimately familiar you know let
me see where you going with this right
that will give me a real valuable input
right say you're missing the plot
totally here you know yeah well so have
you have you like researched any
workshops online that are you know that
might I I don't know I put in everything
they can think of right but you're
looking for more one-on-one type yeah
you know somebody that really you know
maybe a two-on-one or you know but
somebody that's there with you really
helping you yeah I mean like so like
other than maybe through the guild or
through like UCLA Extension another
thought would be you have representation
as a writer oh yeah because that might
be another way is if you can get a
manager or an agent you know a lot of
times they rep there grab bigger clients
than you you might people say guy you
know I'd love to just be able to talk to
this person you know a lot of times that
you know the relationship business you
know so that might be that might be a
way that you can if you can through a
contact like that to representative if
they're like and if you can get an agent
or manager yeah that you can tap okay
you know yeah yeah no I think I think
maybe try it you see what you could you
know look into like literary agents and
managers if you haven't done that and
you have some real if you have some
really solid material especially I think
you've won a competition in or I guess
that some of the things when I went over
like sort of ways to leverage your
material things that might attract a
producer also are the same things that
might attract an agent but I think
that's another way to get to some of
their bigger clients is if you're a
client psyche I'd love to just sit and
kind of talk to this person a little bit
they might be willing to facilitate a
meeting or at the office or something
like that that's another way you mustn't
get in a distributor or sales agent on
early what do they look for before
they'll start to spend their time and
energy or cash themselves your project
yeah it's a good question so you know I
already have some relationship with
distributor so when I walk a script and
it doesn't have anything you know
attached it's a lot easier for me
because they cuz they know me I think if
you have like you have produced credits
at all or okay so you know it's
obviously it's tougher if you don't have
produced credits so you might want to
have a little something going for it
meaning you know if you have like maybe
a director that has some credits
attached or you haven't maybe one actor
that has some credits or something but
enough where they can still put their
fingerprint on this on the script and
they can still help you with the rest of
the cast and so without produced credits
you might need an element some element
to get their attention a director or an
actor maybe yeah or maybe not if they're
a small enough distributor and you have
a good enough pitch just like you're
pitching a producer you might be able to
pitch them and say look I've got this
project and it's based on a really cool
article that I optioned and I'm putting
together the financing myself and I'm
looking for a distributor early most
distributors would love to hear from a
producer early I talk to most just
distribution executives they're like oh
by the time we get the project nothing
we can do with it and then the producer
why couldn't you sell more of it what
can you sell make more money why can you
sell more territories like well we had
no say in the cast we had no say in the
budget we had no say in the store
so I think in that case even a smaller
distributor even if you don't wind up
using them to distribute the film they
can give you a lot of helpful advice
early on so maybe start with the smaller
ones and see if you can get in the door
with a really interesting pitch and if
you're not getting much in the way of
you know response try to get that
director you know with some credits on
board first or getting one actor on
board but be open to letting them give
you some input on the story you know
when I made that movie ninja apocalypse
you know it's funny because you know is
this a genre it's like a Mortal Kombat
whatever I was hired on to do it the
distributor the sales agents were
already hired we had a domestic
distributor and we had a sales agent
before I was even hired by that head had
produced the guys financing and I
remember they said we need a hot girl
we need a fight every seven minutes
every seven minutes need to be a fight
we need swords like E and a lot of
people look this girl I guess is like
soul-crushing right but I didn't look at
it this way I was like this is kind of
cool because alright so we can tell any
story we want we just have to hit these
parameters like a fun game like figuring
out how to just and we decided to do a
remake you guys remember that movie the
Warriors in 1979
well warriors come out and play it's
like a classic yeah we did a ninja
post-apocalyptic ninja remake of the
Warriors I'm like this is cool because
we have all these different clans and
some shoot fireballs and we had when we
have 450 effect shots in that movie
that's like a studio level it was a year
to do all the visual effects on that it
is a year yeah but we had cool martial
artists that Ernie Reyes jr. I played
one of the Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles
and we had carried Ogawa who played
Shang Tsung in Mortal Kombat yeah you've
seen him you know tickles what you've
seen he's like this I make movies and we
had like all these cool martial artists
and stuff and and but I had to hit all
of this and they the sales agent signed
off on carry they're like Oh carry I'll
do well in Japan if you can get carry so
we got carry like we had all these sort
of like rules or like you know we got to
hit this now could me and the other
producer said no screw off we're not
gonna do that yeah but you know we want
to wanna have a chance to make you some
money back so we figure how can we
creatively work within those parameters
to do that so yeah so to answer your
question I say if you don't have credit
so you don't have anything to leverage
if you
credits you would leverage yourself
that's what I can do I can walk in and
say well I've got you know all these
movies so they say they'll listen to me
and say oh yeah we want to be involved
if you don't find something that's
leverageable yeah but yeah don't just
don't cast the whole thing yeah but yeah
an actor or a director something with
credits in the stripper he goes oh this
is real not just another guy off the
street I'll do a song on your movie and
there know if there's a big artist or a
music driven film that might yeah yeah I
mean a bit of a big big artists
typically music is it's yeah it's not in
terms of packaging it's not a big factor
unless the music driven film or unless
you know you got Madonna doing a song
yeah I mean yeah of course but yeah it's
seeming like like hi midnight the one I
told you about with the vampires in the
Old West
I had Stan Winston Studios which at the
time they're defunct but it was like the
Hugh they did the predator
you know they created the president
alien a terminator and I had them
attached and I put them in the pack
because it was an effects driven film so
Stan Winston was like part in the
package it's like yeah you got Vincent
D'Onofrio and Mary Lambert directing and
that's cool but why you also have Stan
Winston Studios that was valid so it was
a music driven film or a really big
artist yeah something yeah so that's I
love I love question I was like it's
like saying how long is a piece of
string depends on the script it really
depends on your script it comes down to
the script right so you know I might
look at a script and go wow you know
this I mean 10 million minimum to do
this I don't even know how you would do
it for less if someone handed me avatar
like I'd be like you can't do this I
know you know I mean so it really
depends on your script there's no ideal
that's what a line producer you know
would help you kind of figure out as you
know you sort of figure out what world
you want to play in
right and I'm trying to think on the
budget you know I'm trying to make sure
one occasion someone they use for sure
stuff like that yeah
what should I aim at being a newbie yeah
I think I think just write what you want
to write don't try to change your story
for budgetary purposes when you're
writing when you're writing just write
just write the story you want to write
because the practicality is the
realities will come in later when I said
you know people often cut their budgets
down I mean they'll have a budget in
mind they'll work with the line produced
will say you know ideally would do this
for a million bucks but I don't think
I'm gonna get million if we can just do
it for 500 I think it'll be easier to
raise the money and that's a fallacy
it's not necessarily easier so there's
no what I'm saying is you know if
they're if if you have a project that
you know it's gonna take a certain
budget to do cook properly don't think
you have to cut that budget down to
attract more investors because it's not
gonna it's not gonna yeah work it
doesn't work that way often it backfires
in your face you know it's just like I
think a lot of times when people put
they do proof of concepts I love the
proof of concepts when I go shoot five
minutes of the movie or mush you a short
film to sell the feature and invariably
they deal with a super low budgets when
they show to an investor investors like
oh oh is this what its gonna look like
and you're like well no it should be
better than this like you're just
hurting yourself you're shooting
yourself in the foot unless you can do
it and make it look as good as it's
gonna look when he finances it or she
finances it it's proof it's do it on
paper do do your pitch back deck sell
them sell yourself don't worry about
wasting money actually shooting a 5
minutes short or something don't don't
bother unless you can do it as good as
the movies going that's my philosophy on
that I've seen that backfire - chief
another question yeah half of the market
for the seller films diminished with
video on demand
someone told me Lionsgate is not you
know spending you know seven eight nine
million dollars buying films out on the
market for distribution is that true I
think the economics are definitely
changing I can't say what Lionsgate is
actually spending or not spending I
don't know but I can tell you that
it's the shift away from DVD and the
shift to streaming and because it is
DVDs almost like a non-existent you know
nowadays has definitely changed the
economics and and how much like you know
like HBO used to actually buy movies and
they don't really there's one movie they
bought last year called the tail I
actually have relationship with that
companies like the only movie they
bought last year so so it's the
economics are changing in terms of how
much companies are spending on I'm not
sure I think that's another good reason
to have a distributor in a sales agent
because they know their their day-to-day
they know what Lions get to know what
the buyers are looking for it literally
changes not even looking weeks a week it
seems like it's changing you know I
remember going to I worked on movie
called harsh times with Christian Bale
and we sold that at Toronto in like 2005
David directed that you know David did
fury Suicide Squad
he wrote training today and I remember
like a salesy he had not done Batman yet
Christian Bale hadn't he he had signed
on to do it and maybe he was going to
shoot if he hadn't done it yet I
remember sales agent telling me
Christian Bale doesn't mean anything at
the time Batman like yeah not yet though
I might get but he's Batman and they're
like yeah but it takes two years to to
germinate in foreign territory he's not
big enough a star he's he's the kid from
Empire of the Sun and he's American
Psycho that's it that's all they know
I'm probably like but who means
something well Christian Slater means
something preciously doesn't done a
movie in 15 years nobody still means
something Ray Liotta still means
something val kilmer something like the
things it blows my mind talking to sales
agents I have know I'm like wow that's
another great reason I have a sales
agent they know because they're at the
markets they're on the phone with buyers
every day they're gonna be your best
friend they can answer it's more
specifically than I can those kind of
question yeah
top ten percent of all the submissions
the letter is that yeah something that
means to I think that does I think that
does yeah I mean it you know it might
not mean as much as if you were a
finalist or a semi-finalists but I think
you can get through doors with that I
mean if you put a query letter together
and again IRA I mentioned the funds for
writers article that I wrote on
screenplay competitions I also wrote one
on how to write a query letter so you
can go to funds for writers and check
out that that website and see the
articles query letter simple start with
the logline
like here you know dear so-and-so
producer here's my police flying
attachment you know whatever you know my
please find below my pitch for whatever
I'm just a log line and then a paragraph
paragraph about yourself and that kind
of you know anything you can leverage
and saying your top ten percent you know
finisher and Nichols is something worth
mentioning for sure in that query letter
I mention that the article so check that
out but yeah that's I think that's
that's valid for sure because Nichols
fellowship is a screenplay competition
it's probably probably the best most
well renowned screenplay competition I
would say probably in the world
it's the biggest like in terms of cachet
they have a lot of a lot of like studio
execs and big name producers judge and
read those scripts if you finish as a
semi-finalists you're gonna get phone
calls
if you finish is a finalist you're going
to take meetings you'll be taking
meetings it's tough to get to that level
the thing with screenplay competitions
you have to remember is they are not
looking for stuff that's gonna get made
they're looking for stuff that's
different that's a big difference
screenplay comment like scripts that you
write like yeah this is marketable this
is really well written it's marketable
it's just like leave the lemon or
whatever that's not what they want they
want scripts that have probably never
get made but they're fresh and different
unique anyone scripts that are calling
cards
the really good talents the writing
talent right boy then we're gonna make
one correct correct
and that's most of the big screen by
competitions or like that start looking
for different they're looking for unique
voices but not necessary scripts that
that are marketable that makes sense all
in the article by the way I mentioned
funds for writers yeah there's a few
good articles on there that's a again
it's another way I try to get you know
information out or help people as you
know write articles for and I think but
I think some of the good some of the my
best ones are on funds for writers so
but it's like just a lot of the stuff
we're talking about is on there so you
can get some details I try to put
specific links like here's the ones I
like the best here's why and I actually
lay out here's the steps to writing the
query letter here's the things that
should be in the query letter so if you
want to leverage that competition win
you know here's here's exactly four or
five beat by beat here's the structure
of your query letter because I don't
want to read a queer there's more on one
page long I don't want to get through
your life story to get to the point you
know but I put specifics in there do the
logline here's what should be in your
logline protagonist what's his goal
who's the antagonist what's the conflict
like I lay it out for you so you know
this is what I think most producers you
know again you know I learned from Bobby
newmeyer I worked for a literary agent I
worked for a post company I worked for a
marketing company I have the indie sort
of indie background but I also have the
studio background I also have the
academic background where I learn from
other producers that would have taken me
years to get to like Terry press from
DreamWorks I would have had to work at
DreamWorks for 15 years before I got an
audience with her instead I went to UCLA
and got an audience with her so you're
getting the benefit of all of these sort
of mentors that I've had that have
passed this so it's not just me saying
this is this experience I had working
for people like Bobby Orr going to
school at UCLA or whatever yeah you kind
of touched on it there a little bit but
as somebody who's new to producing what
could be the first two three steps I can
take to propel myself forward is it
getting experience with somebody else
who has in fact produced obviously
jumping into festivals or
something along those lines giving
myself some practical experience but
from where your yeah if you're going to
you know joint join with another
producer you don't have to bring
something to the table right they're
gonna say okay like so what you know
what do you bring to the table I always
look out as pretty so what I'm gonna
bring to the table if I'm going to come
on board a project but if you're just
starting out me the ID say the the first
thing you should do the easiest way to
get in is find good material find a good
script or option a good article that's a
value that you can bring even if you
don't have relationships with actors or
with you know big-name directors or
something is you can find a good script
you can go on blacklist or spec Scout or
Inc tip or Network just or just network
but you know finding good material
having an eye for good material I think
as start starting out to be a good
breeze you need to find good material
that's where it starts with the story
and then you know you might be able to
attract other bigger producers that you
can start working with and learning from
we got to bring something to the table
you know I'm gonna say you know I could
do this myself you know you see these
proliferation of producer credits right
like on movies is 18 producers you know
it's like well what are they all doing I
hate that because as a Bruce I'm I'm
used to being hands-on doing the work
and I got 79 people taking credit for my
work they don't want the costume
designer credit they want my credit you
know I come on like hey look man I'll
introduce you to this actor friend my I
wanna producer credit you know they'll
ask for like the craft service credit
they hasn't the producer credit so you
know think about what value that you can
bring so if you're just starting off I
think the easiest way to start getting
involved to getting out there this
entice so I found scripts found good
scripts like I told you about the prom
date script and actually wound of
getting made to I didn't make it but I
managed those guys I developed it and
then they sold it I think is gonna be
coming out he if he changed as Josh
Taylor's prom date or something that's
called now but it's yes it's gonna come
out find good material that's how I
would advise you start
walking palmetto that the actual story
of this guy yeah that's that's actually
a big project that I'm working on the
budget that's 30 million it's funny you
mention it I was actually earlier thing
working on the budget for that because
all the new Union rates finally came out
last month
so I was updating the budget on that and
I was pumped I was in Australia for
vacation but I was also looking at some
possible locations while I was there
much to my wife's chagrin I was like oh
yeah this would be great cuz you could
shoot like two Austria's guy you could
shoot California there you shoot the
Caribbean there and palmettos problem is
based on a true story about this guy
Myles Richards we have his life rights
and he was like he was a huge marijuana
smuggler but what made him it's very
topical right now with all the debate
about marijuana and legalization and
stuff it's not what the movies about but
it is sort of topical right
this guy never smuggled the same way
twice he was so creative with how he
smuggled and he could be they've been
smuggling diamonds to give his
doughnuts it didn't matter it's not even
about marijuana as much as willful Wall
Street's about stocks which it's not
right that this isn't really about it's
about this guy and this life
transformation he goes through and like
sort of he gets a final gets comput it's
him 20 years to catch this guy because
he was so creative with how he did he he
actually he intentionally I think he
like intentionally sunk a ship off the
coast of Florida with all the weeds in
these airtight watertight bags and then
filed a salvage permit with the Coast
Guard and so every day they got to know
him he's out there bringing parts of the
boat up you know for months and he has
the weed and the parts of bonis right
under the Coast Guard's nose because
he's a salvage operative things right
some of these stories are in this in the
script yeah it's really fascinating this
guy's life and he finally for 20 years
he got caught he spent 11 years in
prison at Lompoc I think four were in
solitary confinement he wouldn't rat on
a name his friend but he finally got out
he went you know like legit started a
construction business made millions of
dollars like legally but sky it's such a
fascinating life it's like one of those
Henry Hill from Goodfellas or
you know we're talking about catch me if
you can frankly I've been at big nail
it's one of those larger than life
stories where the story it's a very it's
a big movie with a lot of locations and
takes place over 20 years of this guy's
life but so fascinating and and myself
and the writer producing with Ed Asner
you know he's been around for a long
time so Ed's a producer on this
we just got Clint Eastwood to read it
which was amazing
cuz Edie could just call Clint and say
hey will you read this thing it's like
okay but Clint just didn't movie called
the mule and which is very liking this
older guy some ugly drugs you know it's
not what I movies about was just too
similar but just then we say to Clint
well who do you see directing and or
starring in this and just getting Clint
Eastwood to say I'm just making
something but say Clint says we're gonna
we're trying to get this answer if Clint
says oh we're on Ryan Gosling and makes
it that help swim and or I call Ryan
Gosling's Asian go so Clint Eastwood
just read the script and thinks Ryan
Gosling should play this if Clint
Eastwood says that they might actually
say okay and we'll take a look at it but
it's very cool project so we'll see if I
can get off the ground it said it's very
big much bigger than anything I've ever
done so and I've been working on for a
couple years developing and packaging
and stuff so don't think well I do why'd
you want me to bring that up is there a
reason is it cool it's a cool story it
is it is a cool thing do it not as a
criminal just dude is legit that's right
well you know we've made jokes about
this miles has said to Gemini's like I
could just do one more load and finance
the movie man it will just feel like all
oh like no miles no no more legs like
I'm just kidding man I'm just kidding
yeah
I'll do one more load man I will get
this yeah he's a girl I'll be at the
premiere we'll be off the coast of
Portugal man it'll be awesome like no
listen no yes he's guys yeah yeah what
he wants that's what he wants he said
we'll be doing a load man like no miles
we won't know the winner but ya know
that and that's but that's the kind of
larger-than-life characters you know you
find a character like that find a story
like that and you're gonna attract other
producers and other interested you know
interested people so yeah well I hope
again I hope this was beneficial for you
guys man you know yeah cool cool awesome
thank you appreciate that